Hi and welcome back to another VC libraries.
Open code review.
Today we'll be looking at a C23 feature.
This is a paper 1899 revision,
3 views stride on the GitHub PR is 2981
from our GitHub contributor and I'm going
to try to pronounce this Jay Mazurkiewicz
apologies if I've gotten that wrong.
I am quite familiar with
people mispronouncing my name,
so this is yet another ranges feature ranges.
Added to CBS Plus 20 and are
being greatly expanded in C + 23,
so we're going to look at the paper.
We're gonna look at the PR.
It's about 1000 lines,
but that's split between
product code and test code.
And let's say we have a
note from our contributor.
I've stood qualified all calls
to forward and move and tests
because the next cling release is
going to warn about unqualified,
steadfast calls.
That seems like it's going to actually
be quite an obnoxious forwarding that
we may need to suppress throughout
the test code base because we love
our using namespace stood in tests,
but I suppose that's acceptable for this PR.
OK,
so let's take a quick look at
our tracking issue and the paper,
and then we'll actually review
the PR so our tracking issue
as usual after each G 21 or
Standardization Committee meeting,
we go through and file tracking issues
for all the papers that were voted in,
so this was voted in just 10 days.
We've got a feature test macro,
CPP, Lib ranges,
strides set the year and month of acceptance.
So July 2022.
And other than that, no other notes here.
Here's where we'll note,
like, oh this, you know,
has a bunch of patch papers
that also affect it,
or other interesting
considerations like compiler stuff.
Here is the paper.
Let's jump to the proposed wording.
So what's being added in the ranges
namespace is a new class stride
view specializing enable borrow
range for it and then a stride
object in the views namespace.
Hurting for it,
this advances over N elements at a time.
So basically,
if you have a range of elements you can
say I want to look at every other element,
every third element here.
They've got an example.
If you have a views iota
that counts from zero to 12,
I believe exclusive.
You could look at every third
element and this will print 0369.
If you stream that to a no stream.
Or you could also do it in review reverse.
So this is a nice way to skip.
Elements if you ever need that,
so looking at the class definition here,
this looks very much like other
views we have.
I'm sort of just quickly scanning
for anything that is unusual or
unusually different from other
views that I've seen.
OK, so there's some drafting
notes about end computing missing.
OK. And then the stride view
also comes with an iterator,
so we're going to have a nested iterator.
This is also a very common pattern
that we've seen in other views.
A lot of machinery here,
because this could be up to
a random access iterator.
Essentially, if you have a vector
of a million elements and you're
skipping every other element,
you can totally say I want to advance
by 100 places and the stride view
iterator will know how many times to advance.
Underlying iterator.
Uh, kind things about the iterator concept.
I'm also trying to think of
any LDG issues or other papers
that could interact with this.
I'm not thinking of any that would be
concerning and then future to macro.
OK, so I don't see anything too surprising
or scary in the paper, which is good.
So let's start reviewing the PR.
I'll keep this open for a second.
Let me split this.
So that's the left that's to the right, OK?
So files changed.
Let's alt click and minimize everything.
OK, so small.
Changes first we've got in our center
and turn ahead of rivals Core H.
The new features being mentioned
under C + 23.
That's correct.
Make sure the paper numbers correct.
1899 R 3 views,
double colon stride excellent.
It is in sorted order.
The only 818 hundred series paper so far.
We're also gaining a feature test macro.
Let's make sure the spelling is correct.
There it is.
It is.
Let's make sure it's in the right section
in the C + 23 section it's guarded by.
CP Lib concepts.
Because it's a ranges paper,
this will eventually evaporate once
all of our supported front end support
concepts and the macro value looks correct.
Yep,
there it is and it is in sorted order.
STA and then STR perfect.
OK, nothing else to do there.
A feature test macro test is being updated.
New. Macros being mentioned everywhere.
Value we got a typo.
This looks to have been retyped and
we got a 2021 so this is an issue.
This is why I always search because maybe,
uh, 3% of the time we find an issue here.
Hippo this value should be blocked.
There we go. Start review.
OK, other than that everything was good here.
Umm, I see two issue or one
thing to check and then one issue
so sorted order looks good,
ranges starts and ranges stride and
then we go on to raw memory algorithms.
We do have to check that if we're not.
If the feature is not enabled,
the feature just macro should not be there.
We recently fixed some accumulated
inconsistency so it's good that this is here.
The one thing that doesn't need to happen,
which is not a bug.
In this PR, but it's.
Race condition between PR's.
Umm is that uh for features
that are guarded by concepts.
The feature test macro tests used
to say if we're in 23 mode and we're
not being compiled by EDG because
EDG is the front end that does
not yet fully support concepts.
I have a PR that I just created
that cleans this up so to avoid a
stealth merge conflict we should
preemptively update this PR.
I need to find it. It's already approved.
It's enhancement.
Here it is.
Let me just go into the PR and grab
the appropriately fixed lines.
Yeah, so for consistency,
we're now going to guard these
with if we're in 23 mode and
CPP Lib Concepts is available,
and then we cite the tracking issue just
so that we have a single way to test for.
Are we in concepts mode.
We had, like both ways scattered
throughout the code base,
and it was increasingly confusing, so I will.
Add this here. Let's see.
OK, and then we want.
Let's make sure we get the right line.
Yes, it's a 23 line.
I certainly don't want to
suggest the wrong change,
but I can make a suggestion
here and justice replace this.
Then we can actually look at the edit.
Yeah so keep CXX 23 UM and changes that.
Yeah, that looks good.
Let's see.
Let me explain this properly, OUM.
This is consistent with the.
Current state of the file, but my. ER is, uh?
Overhauling the. Umm? Hattern
is UM.
Changing these lines.
But it's actually not accessed with
the current state of the file,
because the file is inconsistent.
Let me rephrase that.
This is considered, yeah,
it's I'm trying to not spend
too much time on this,
but I do want to at least
provide a correct explanation.
This is consistent with the occurrence above,
but my PR blah.
Is changing these lines to be globally
consistent to avoid a stealth merge conflict?
Actually we should just say thus.
This should. Be changed to.
OK. That's that look,
this is consistent with the current above,
but my PR 2994 is changing these
lines to be globally consistent.
Thus this should be changed to still 23,
but test concepts and site OK.
Do you want to make the previous
comment suggestion as well as opposed
to saying type of this value should be?
The typo oh this year.
Ohh yeah I could I could just
make a suggestion.
I could definitely do that.
Typo. Hey, how come I don't get the.
Suggestion thingy? That's weird.
You can just do a three tick
block with the suggestion adding.
I'm just surprised that I don't.
You know, maybe.
Instead of typing that out,
I'm going to be super lazy.
I'm going to delete this comment and then
see if I get it for a fresh comment.
I do haha. OK, interesting.
I didn't know that. Yeah,
I I suspected like it does seem like a bug.
I don't know if it's a bug or by design,
but I am lazy. OK, there we go.
Yes, and I was going to say typo,
but I think that's clear in context.
OK. Thanks.
OK, that looks like it for the future.
Just back to test, uh,
we now have two new tests being added.
I'll quickly check this one for test that
it works and other tests that runtime
checks will terminate the program.
So we are citing the correct
paper number 189903.
It's in sorted order.
I want to make sure that the tests
are spelled exactly the same,
because this is only checked
in the internal test harness.
Yep, that all looks good.
So tests are being added to the list.
Excellent,
I've got our copyright license banner.
Uh, because it's ranges.
We need strict and concepts.
It's a C + 23 feature, so it's latest matrix.
Yep, so that's all our good compiler options.
Same here.
Strict concept slaves matrix with our banner.
Ohh, quickly look.
This we got the banner OK,
I'll review the test later and
then here it's a large diff.
700 lines or 600 lines.
Copyright license banner.
OK, we'll come back to this.
Let's look at.
The Natfiz and the product code.
OK,
so this is going to need to
be triple mirrored over to VI.
Think we're currently In Sync
with all the visualizer changes,
so this will just need to be
mirrored in isolation.
I think it is reasonable to
do this as part of the PR,
so we're going to add strive
view with all these views.
There's been no real attempt to sort them,
so appending to the end is fine.
And then we have an optional
data member called the stride.
I do want to make sure that this is
actually occurring in the product code.
So.
Look for occurrences of under
score capital structure,
period.
It's going to be a data
member of Stride View.
Where is it? Here it is.
Stride 0. And missing,
do we already visualize and
missing we don't what is missing?
Is missing in the. PR text
missing is depicted. As.
A local variable of NT.
It looks like the implementation no.
Here it is true view Iterator
has a missing data member.
It's a strip view iterator.
That's what I'm looking at,
but the stride view itself OK,
the stride view itself only has stride.
That's interesting.
This also implies that perhaps
in the future we might want to
visualize the view iterators.
Currently,
I think we don't attempt to do that.
That could be a future extension,
but certainly not a defect in this PR. OK,
so it is called under score capital stride.
This looks great.
OK, I will make a note that
we do need to mirror this.
I'll just note it on an empty
line because it's not an issue
with any of the code above.
Note, Umm well need to.
Triple mirror this to the VSS internal
repo where the visualizers are stored.
OK. It's fairly uncommon,
so noting it is a good reminder.
OK, let's actually look at the product code,
and I do want to cross off things
as I see them, so I'm going to get a
web capture of the proposed wording.
Let's Scroll down. All the way.
We already looked at the feature to macro.
OK, backup capture.
Get a larger pen, OK?
OK, there we go. Umm, so ranges?
Uh, we've got stride view and.
OK, this is the class declaration.
The question is, is it
occurring in the correct place?
Because we try to keep them in
the same order as the standard.
This doesn't actually say
where it should be added.
So the editors could choose
wherever interesting we will hope
that they choose the same place.
In fact, this even just says
add the following subclause,
which implies that it's
just going to be appended.
I suppose we could look at the
current order of the subclauses,
I'm assuming chunk by is
probably one of the last.
OK, so it's 24 two range of sin
and then 24/7 range adapters.
OK, so like 24/7 I can't be right.
Might be 20. Ohh, did the clauses
the clauses might have got renumbered
between when this paper was initially
submitted so fairly low number.
So I'm probably looking at the wrong section.
Where is ranges 26. 7 range it out. OK,
so the numbers in the proposal are outdated,
but indeed chunk by view is the last one.
So pending. OK, so this does
seem to be in the right place.
So we got the stride view.
Uh, let's look at.
Interesting, this does not match.
This is template on oh,
I see it's being reversed.
OK, let's actually look at the.
Definition here.
OK so this is being reversed.
The proposal depicts template on an
input range V that has to be a view.
This definition says template on a
view V that needs to be an input range.
And then drive public
interface drive view view.
OK, this arts all fine,
but the reversal here is interesting.
What does again?
I'm looking at the wrong thing.
Uh, what does something like
chunk by view look like?
Chunk by view is templated on
a range that requires view.
So the standard is quite consistent
template on the range require view.
And this is just reversing it.
And let me look at our implementation.
Again, I can look at chunk by view
for precedent since it's above.
Here it is. That's pretty big.
Again, template on range requires view.
I think this should be reversed.
It may not actually make a difference.
But it really seems that we should
be following the standard here,
unless there's a good reason to do otherwise.
Yes, OK so.
Uh, let's see.
The. Proposal depicts. Umm?
Templates on. Input range V.
That's then constrained by requires.
View TV. Umm? I, I think I might
know why this person did this.
Can you look at the other, the non
input or the stronger than input range?
Version of Strife view.
Is there 10 the specialization?
OK yeah. Do we have a whole?
We do not have a whole
specialization of stride view.
Oh, there's only primary specialization,
in which case it makes
sense to make view the.
Primary concept, but if there's
not an extra specialization there,
it doesn't make any sense.
Yeah, the iterator operators are
things that are like constrained
with requires the base needs
to be a random access range,
but that's at the iterator level.
Yeah, I think they should be reversed. OK so.
We should follow that here.
Unless there's a good reason to do.
Otherwise, OK. The proposal depicts
template on input range V that's
then constrained by requires V.
We should follow that here unless
there's a good reason to do otherwise.
OK. OK, so if we reverse those
we get a template on input
range view requires view view.
Class stride view Dr publicly
from view interface drive.
View view. OK so that looks good.
And we are definitely within ranges.
We're outside views.
OK, so private data members.
Uh, comment out no unique address
because we can't actually use that yet.
View range, so that's the base, and then
we're going to have a range difference.
T view stride OK, these are exposition only.
We're going to have an iterator.
So that's this and this.
We're going to have a template on
class based high class iterator base.
Uh, template for a forward range
based tie plus iterator base.
Specialized on base time private
using base category.
OK so this is going to implement
some of the category stuff down here.
Let me see if I can find that.
Here we go. The iterator concept.
That's iterator concept.
Here's iterator category. OK.
So the member type of name iterator category.
Here it is is defined if and only
if base models forward range.
There's the forward range and in that
case iterator category is defined as follows.
Let C denote the type iterator traits
iterator to F base iterator category.
So iterator traits iterator T of base
iterator category. We need type name.
So using base category.
OK, that's reasonable.
And then publicly we're going
to say and then this is OK.
It's not too long.
Umm,
if C which is that type based
category models derived from
random access iterator tag.
So if base category is derived
from random access iterator
tag then conditional it should
be random access iterator tag.
Yep otherwise it should be C base category.
Yep, that looks exactly right,
so this is implementing.
This stuff. OK, so this is all done.
And then we've got iterator,
so that's a peer.
OK template on a bool which
is going to be constant.
Constant class under score capital iterator.
It's ugly because it's exposition
only drives publicly from the
iterator base of maybe constant view.
OK so apply constant to the view.
OK. So that looks correct.
And then let's actually look
at what's that's doing.
It's going to be down here.
OK, so we've already seen
this is the outer class.
We've already commented on
that O template on Vulcans.
This is a stride view iterator.
And then we get that type def.
OK, so that base class isn't depicted using
parent is maybe constant stride view.
OK, so that's going to be this here.
OK, so let's see private.
We grant friendship.
To the stride view.
Is that necessary?
Yes, because as an iterator it can see
private data members of the parent,
and this will allow the parent
to see private data members and
member functions of the iterator.
Interestingly, this also grants
friendship to any other nested classes.
I don't think that's going
to be an issue here,
but we have seen that in other types OK,
and this uses the extended front syntax
that doesn't say class or anything,
so that's awesome.
Avoids potentially declaring anything using
a parent tie is maybe constant stride view.
That's parent,
using bases may be consequences view.
Yep, using base iterator
his iterator to your base.
So that's just for our convenience.
Using Base Sentinel and Sentinel tea base.
OK, so that's all good.
We got this and this.
Now we're gonna have no unique
address because these could be empty.
Again, this is for the future.
They're currently commented
out base iterator current.
And then value initialize it OK and then
based Sentinel end value initialize that OK.
Stride is arranged difference tea.
It's initially 0 same with missing.
OK, so you've got all this.
And then we're going to have a
constexpr constructor for the iterator.
That's going to take and this
is exhibition only,
so it can be private.
Parent type star parent.
This is not applying top
level counts to the pointer,
but I'll accept that I'm not too
worried when it's fairly small.
Base Iterator current with a
following under score so don't
get any shadowing that's good.
That's our usual convention range difference.
T base missing. This is occurring.
At least four times.
It is kind of like we could move
this up and put different type
above and then just use it.
It's not too verbose.
I'm tempted, but I won't ask for that change.
UM, because this is at least
following the standard,
the standard doesn't bother to provide
the different type up until down here.
Umm, OK so range difference.
Tea base missing that defaults to zero.
OK wrap for clang format?
We're conditionally no except.
This is common to strengthened,
which is reasonable.
It is depicted in the standard,
even though it's exposition only,
so that seems fine.
We're no, except if this is no
except ranges end parent range,
because that's where we got a call there,
and the base iterator needs to be no throw,
move constructible because we do
move it and the base Sentinel needs
to be known for move constructible.
Yep. OK, that seems exactly correct.
Current move current under score and
should be ranges end of the parent range,
stride parent stride missing
is whatever missing.
They're giving us OK, that's good.
OK, now this public using different
type range difference to base using
value type range value to base
using iterator concepts see below.
Let's see below, that's this here.
We've already got the iterator category,
but the iterator concept says if
base models random access range,
it should be a random access or A tag.
If it is a bidirectional range,
then it's the bidirectional iterator tag.
If it's forward range forward iterator tag.
Otherwise input iterator tag exactly correct.
OK, bunch of conditionals.
It's all done.
And we've already got the iterator
category coming from the base class,
and indeed it's not always present.
Umm?
We've got,
yeah,
this is a pattern that Clang format
currently does not handle well,
so we suppress it.
Here we've got a default constructor
requires default initialize
table of the base iterator.
That's our convenience type.
Def defaulted,
that's good.
And then we have a constexpr constructor from
an iterator with the opposite constant other.
And then.
This is being strengthened for noexcept.
Let's check this if the base iterator
is nothrow constructible from.
Iterator to fu.
That is what we're trying to do,
convert here.
If my base iterator is ohh because this
only occurs when I'm consed and the
other iterator is not consed O iterator.
Tofu is the others iterator in that case.
So this is correct.
Is this thing no through constructible?
And is the Sentinel Nothrow constructible and
we don't do anything other than copy strides?
OK, so that is correctly strengthened.
It requires constant, so that's this here.
And convertible to here I'm looking for
anything reversed because convertible
and constructible take opposite orders.
It's very easy to flip them.
So here are convertible to iterator,
T view base iterator and convertible
2 Sentinel TV based Sentinel.
Yep, that's good.
So the constraint is correct.
This we're going to move the current
or move other current, move other end,
copy the stride, copy the missing.
Yep, that's all good.
I don't even really need to
look at the definition below,
although I I will Scroll down
and take a look at it.
OK, so now we've got observers.
This is a pure observer,
so it doesn't need to be no discard
according to our conventions.
Context per base iterator base ref ref.
We're strengthening it when is no throw
move constructible V the base iterator
because we're going to move it out, Yep.
Uh,
But if we're an L value notice guard concept,
spur cons based iterator ref base
constel ref no accept return current.
OK, so these are good.
Then we've got drafing.
So if you deraf, yeah,
you really should be inspecting that.
That's pure observer,
so it's no discard context, product type,
auto dref constant going to strengthen or no.
Except if this is no except recurrent.
Yep, that's right.
We do have the content there.
Yep OK,
we do have a let me scroll to the left.
If iterator debug level is not zero,
we verify.
That current does not end because
you try to be dereferencing.
Here I'm looking for like copy paste errors.
Can I dereference stride,
view and iterator that's right.
Same comment return DRF current.
Yep, that's what we're supposed to do.
OK,
so here when we pre and post increment
those uh or the pre increment
that is ignorable so we don't
want no discard context iterator.
If opt plus plus.
Again, IDL,
check the currents not end,
cannot increment stride view and
data rate or correct O missing.
We do not say range is double colon.
This should be capital ranges just like this.
This is just purely a style thing.
This is not actually vulnerable
to any sort of hijacking.
But in the future,
it could allow us to like replace
stuff with like inline namespaces.
I don't think I need to comment why,
UM, here, uh, this is just clearly a,
I think O because range is advanced,
is probably used down here.
OK, so missing is here actually do want
to check the definition, although I'm
confident this is going to be correct.
A plus plus equivalent to missing is.
I see why it was.
It was a copy paste and then replaced
from the standardized. Very tempting.
Of course missing is ranges,
advanced current stride End
returned to you for this.
OK, so we do have the return.
That's all good.
We got the precondition,
I'll just cross that out.
For now we've got the plus.
Plus then we got a post increment.
Sex for void plus plus int plus plus
Dr for this nothing else to do.
But here and again we could
discard this quite easily.
Counts per iterator plus plus int if we
have forward range base then we need
to do the usual dance auto temporaries.
This increment return the temporary.
Yep, that's all good.
Decrementing constexpr iterator
ref decrement requires byte irange.
Base range of advanced current
missing minus stride.
Let's check what this is doing.
Let's see, we've got this one and this one.
OK, so should be ugly.
Ranges advanced, correct current,
missing minus stride set missing to
be 0 return this OK, that's good.
And then let's go back U here let's
this one OK constexpr iterator by value.
Redeck int or sorry post Dec INT
requires bidirectional range base
auto temp is DRF this three deck.
DRF this return temp. Yep that's all good.
OK, now we've got plus equal, uh,
scroll over to the right. A little bit.
OK, good constexpr iterator ref again.
This is ignorable oplus SQL difference
type off. This is a fairly large function,
so taking by constant value is good.
This requires random access range base.
I'm all I'm running for my mental
checklist of do we need like virtual?
Do we need? You know?
No, except and you know things like
that and functions. This is all fine.
If the offset is greater, zero,
OK here I do want to check the
definition because this is doing work.
Yeah, we did this one.
OK, so preconditions.
That's what this is checking.
If north is positive ranges distance,
current north is true.
That is negative.
The effects paragraph applies recondition.
OK so.
This is first we're going to check
can we even do this multiplication?
So this is very good.
We don't wanna do an integer overflow
while checking for the precondition.
OK, so. This also seems really familiar.
I think we solved this problem elsewhere.
Although I can't remember where.
And we've got a two-part test here.
OK, so. If the offset.
That we're trying to.
OK so here. Offsets coming in.
We know the offsets positive,
so that's N positive,
so if N is positive, that's where we are.
The offset could be one or more.
If it's a one. Then this is 0 and.
We're gonna be fine.
Well, we can't possibly overflow,
so the offset could be one,
or if the offset isn't one then we
need to make sure that offset minus
one times stride has to be less than
or exactly equal to numeric limits,
difference type Max parenthesize to
avoid macro expansion from evil headers.
This is correct because we've
prevented division by zero.
Then we phrased it in a way that
will detect overflow without
actually causing overflow.
The error here we will report
cannot advance stride view iterator
past end Integer Overflow.
OK, assuming we can compute this expression,
then we can check this that the
ranges macro distance current end.
Must be strictly greater than stride
times offset or north minus one.
That's going to be true.
Can't advanced drive View Iterator
Pass end OK perfect.
That's the end of our check effects
equivalent two if N is greater,
0 missing is ranges advance
current stride times off end.
Otherwise, I'll say F off is less than 0.
Ranges advance current stride times off,
plus missing set missing to be 0.
Returned your for this OK excellent.
And minus SQL, why am I scrolling up here?
I want to scroll up here.
So that's a plus.
Equal minus equal looks pretty simple,
has expert iterator ref equals
difference type off requires
random access range base return.
Do you rough this plus equal negative off OK.
We got a square bracket.
OK going back to things that are
notice card because if you score
bracket iterator you really should
be looking at what you're getting.
Concepts for Deco type auto square
bracket comes different type off.
It's constant. We're going to strengthen it.
We're no except if this is
no except expression, OK.
And then requires.
Random access range base because
you need that to do subscripting
return DRF of DRF this was off.
OK, that's good.
Then we're going to get notice
card friends using our macro.
Umm,
so yeah,
because these are all equality
and comparison operators.
I still don't fully understand why the
standard has to specified this full
complement of operators rather than
purely relying on spaceship for completely
new tech that's not adapting existing.
I don't actually understand
why we're doing this. Ohh,
the iterator might not be 3 way comparable.
Nice, OK, because it's not.
It's an adapting arrange that range
may not be spaceship and lightened,
so we do need these, that's sad.
In the sense that we could have required
a standard could have required hey,
if you want to use these ranges,
you know everything's got to be 3 or
comparable, but this makes it more usable.
So at the cost of a little bit
more spam the implementation.
OK, so notice guard friend Constexpr
bool up equal taking a constant
iterator of it and a default setting Lt.
We're going to strengthen the no except.
Implicitly convert to bool because
that's what we're doing it current
double equal it end,
that is indeed strengthened return
whether it current is it end
because we know our own end,
so we can use the default Sentinel T and
then that's just one notice guard friend,
equal concentrator left iterator ref
right again, we're strengthening.
Plus you convert to bool,
left current is right current.
Requires quality comparable base iterator.
Yep, that's this requirement.
And then the highly repetitive,
less than greater or less equal,
greater or equal all require
random access range base.
So we're going down here.
Oops, I did not actually want to scroll up,
and that's not good and try it the other way.
OK. I'm highlighting just so I
know how high and low to scan.
No scared friend concepts for bool less
than greater, less equal, greater, equal.
That is actually the standard order
which is great.
under score left under score right?
We're strengthening.
Implicitly convert to bool.
OK, we need the same expression here.
So less than his left,
left and right, left, left and right.
Greater is right, left, left, right,
left and left less than or equal.
Is this one's the fun one?
I'm listener equal if I'm not greater.
And that means I'm not reverse less than no,
not right less than left,
not right less and left.
Yep, that's right,
and then greater equals not less,
not left less and right not
left left and right.
OK good, no copy paste errors,
they're all strengthened.
They all require random access range.
We just looked at the returns perfect.
OK, so that's all these.
And then spaceship.
No scared friend concepts for auto operator,
spaceship comes iterator ref left.
Consider right right?
No except when no except
spaceship left and right.
Yep,
requires got to be random access range
and three comparable base Iterator
return left current spaceship right
current OK operators and I love seeing
these these be notice card friends or
just friends in general because that
means very low impact on standard.
For modules,
if these were separate functions,
I'd need to export all.
Also, this is great for throughput,
so I'm very happy to see that the standard
is mandating those no scar friend constexpr.
Ohh what. This is a bug in the standard.
These should not be returning iterator refs.
These should be returning PR values iterator.
Wow, that's super bad.
I wonder has anybody filed an LWG
issue about that? There's no way.
Oh no, OK, it's only in the synopsis.
Yeah. Yeah, we'll probably get it fixed.
Editorially what is this 1st 1899?
I'll go make sure the editors are aware.
OK awesome, thanks Casey.
Yeah, the intention is clearly because
the definition doesn't have those refs
and these refs are just clearly bogus.
We don't even need to file an LG issue and
our contributors already already fixed it,
so we're more correct than the
standard excellent notice guard.
Fran comes expert iterator by value
operator plus taking constant iterator
of it and it counts difference type off.
We are just using empty comment to hard
ramp requires or random access range base.
And then we're going to make an auto
copy of it copy plus SQL off return.
Copy. That's fine, Umm?
And then what if we reverse the parameters?
No scarf Fran context for iterator
by value plus constant force type
off considerate or if it again
random access range,
copy the IT increment by off return copy,
so that's good.
Those are the pluses.
That's good Fran conspirator
by value conspirator.
It minus an off prior to our
annual access range auto copies it
copy minus equal off return copy.
Yep, that's good. Of subtract 2 iterators.
No scared friend constexpr difference
type minus consider reflekt consider
if right here we have a strengthening.
No except no except left current
minus right current.
That is the fundamental option we need to do.
Because there's the iterators.
Then we just do math on the missing
and stride. OK, that seems right.
OK requires size Sentinel 4 iterator.
Kbase iterator Tabasco base
iterator based iterator OK.
That means can we subtract essentially?
OK, so.
Here,
let's actually look at the definition
because we're doing real work.
Ah, here we go.
Two others let N be X current
minus Y current constant modif is
left current minus right current.
OK, so we've got that.
If base models forward range.
So if context for forward
range base then north.
Which is the diff.
Plus X missing minus Y missing plus left
missing minus right missing all divided
by X ride all divided by left stride.
OK, that's good.
Otherwise, if N is negative.
If strictly less than zero,
then return negative dive seal
which we already have negative
diff or north and left stride.
Otherwise Division seal of next
Stride Diff left stride OK.
That's good.
OK, so I'll back up here, not enough.
Like a pier.
That was the subtractor iterators.
Now notice card friend.
It's expert difference type minus of
default Sentinel test and iterator refx.
For strengthening, no except of.
OK, the fundamental operation
we're doing is it end minus it.
Current OK requires size Sentinel four.
OK, this one is a little bit different.
Sentinel keybase iterator T base so
base Sentinel base iterator good.
Again, we're doing a bit of work here.
Let's actually check the definition.
This is Sentinel minus iterator.
So where is it Sentinel minus iterator?
This should be divisive seal.
X End, which is it end minus X current
it current and ex stride perfect.
That's this one.
OK, and then iterator minus default Sentinel.
Here no Scott friend cause expert
difference type not minus considerato
ref default sent strengthen again the
same fundamental operation requires
seasonal 4 again senility based iterator.
Tabasco based Sentinel based iterator.
This one is just going
to return the negation.
Because their arguments are flipped.
Yep, that looks right.
OK, it or move O if you interwove you
really do need to look at the results,
so that's why no discard friend.
That's expert range R value reference dbase.
It remove constant iterator refit
restraint Oh no not strengthening.
It's mandatory no except if no except no
except if no except range is it removed
at current and that's what we return good.
And then last we have a returning void,
so none of that notice card stuff
friend comes exper void it.
Or swap considerato rough left.
Consider right, right?
Again, mandatory no,
except if no except ranges that are
swap left current right current.
Rap requires indirectly swappable
iterator Tbas,
so base iterator return ranges
it or swap the current recurrent
OK and of class for iterator.
Back to stride view.
OK, all the work's going on in the iterator.
Strive view is less complicated questions
before we move on we got some questions.
Comments in the chat here.
OK, let's go up.
That's a lot of questions.
Let me expand this window.
OK, so Nicole's offer to upstream
the visualizer changed into VS.
Thank you.
Casey says if you're watching this and
you someday decide to write a proposal
for the C Plus Standard Committee,
please don't include any section numbers.
They're always just noise.
Agreed,
Tyler's asking this is just
alternate syntax for concepts.
Yes, is your goal to match the sternal cases.
I assume this is asking for the the
reversal of that forward range and view.
Yeah, it's awesome. Yeah, Casey says.
Not necessarily all cases,
but we do like to match the standard text
when there's no motivation to do otherwise.
Yeah, basically we're generally safe
if we do what the standard says.
Not not always.
Sometimes the standard wants us to do
something that's not directly as depicted,
but most of the time, if we.
Implement something that looks
very much like the standard.
We will get everything right anytime
we modify our implementation
with respect to the standard,
it could be observable, not always,
but there's a surprising
number of ways that small,
apparently innocent tweaks
could affect users.
So in the case of like,
what are we actually templated on?
And what is constrained?
I think they're actually equivalent
according to how concepts works,
but I'm not 100% sure and.
Even if they do happen to be equivalent,
it's worth following the principle
that if we have our implementation
match the standard as much as possible,
then any remaining deviations
from the standard will be things
that are necessary for either
performance or conformance,
or some weird implementation specific thing,
so it'll draw attention to those cases.
So that's why we're going to comment
on this class definition here,
that reversing what are we templated
on and then what's an additional
constraint seems to be unnecessary,
and we shouldn't do that.
Even if we're not exactly sure
whether it's observable or not, OK?
Let's see some discussion between
Nicole and Casey about when do
we define iterator category?
We only define iterator.
Sorry,
say that this basically comes
down to what is the type not
defined iterator category when
the underlying range is input.
That's specifically says we
define iterator category,
but only when the underlying
range is at least forward and.
I I brought forth the point that
single pass iterators might be move
only in in the range of design,
in which case they might not have
a corresponding iterator category.
But that doesn't explain why we don't
define one when they are copyable,
and they could actually model the C++.
The legacy Iterator concepts we yeah,
because yeah, if you have if you have
a classic input iterator and then you
just start skipping every third element,
you're still an input iterator,
so that seems like an interesting.
It's essentially a design question,
or at this point it would be LBG question.
So the PR is definitely implementing
what the standard says,
but it's a good question.
Like why does the standard say that?
I'm not actually sure.
Let's see,
is this true for like other views as well,
like I don't know transform view,
I feel like should be probably an
input iterator most of the time.
Yeah, I can't remember seeing this elsewhere.
It it came from Iterator base so
we could search for any currencies
of thing because this is one one
thing that's nice about following
the same naming conventions all the
time is that we can just search.
And if we've done our job of.
Following precedent,
well then we can look for other currencies.
We have very few things called.
We do call iterator based,
no do we call base iterator?
What was it?
Iterate array, oh oh, that's a global thing.
Ohh, I think I do want to comment separately
that we should not shadow this iterator.
Base is a global STL name for within stood
for either iterator B0 or Interbase 12.
We should not shadow this even within
a class. It's way too confusing.
Yeah, O maybe elsewhere we've
called if we've had it basically
by the name of the property like.
Category base or iterator concept
base or something like that.
Yeah, here's a type def called Base iterator.
Can you think of any ranges that
have had that sort of helper thing?
We would have called it like,
yeah, category based.
I guess you said no off the top of my head,
but I know there are something I could do.
Ohi oh here we go Interbase.
This is the precedent.
Interbase is pretty neutral.
OK I will recommend this because
otherwise it's way too confusing.
Let me actually put this
outer inner base in Lacey.
Split View was probably
one of the first ones. OK.
So I'm going to want, uh,
where it was extra utility, you think?
I know this after a zillion
years working on the STL,
but I forget where things are defined.
What is defined iterator base?
I wanted to say X utility add sex memory.
I've tried to get.
I'm guessing it picky about like
shadowy and tasks like if somebody
defines a test variable named count.
I've basically stopped complaining that hey,
this could chat with the name of you
know the student count algorithm,
but for classes in the STL,
I feel very strongly that
we should not shadow them,
even if there's no compiler warnings.
Just way too confusing if
we do a global search.
OK, so hit Y to get Perma links.
I'll copy the whole thing just
so you can see the context here.
OK, I wanna comment here.
There we go. This shadows.
This name. Shadows on important base
class used throughout. The STL.
It's brilliant base class type def.
Umm? To avoid this shadowing,
which greatly complicates searches even.
In the absence of compiler warnings,
I'm trying to provide rationale so
the contributor understands like
why we're so nitpicky about this.
I said let's look at ranges and look
for an occurrence of inter base.
We should not use the term inter base.
We should use category, base category base.
Oh because it's providing the
iterator category. Good point.
Yeah we have 123.
4-5 distinct category bases in the,
uh, uh, ranges header.
This seems to be the
standard name for this thing.
That's definitely become the most common.
Yeah, and the the more
we follow this pattern,
the easier it is to understand.
So thank you. OK, uh, let's see.
We should use the name category
based as the space class exists
to conditionally provide.
Iterator category.
OK, let's see if that looks right.
This name iterator based shadow is
an important base class type def
used throughout the STL iterator
base to avoid the shadowing,
which greatly complicates searches even
in the absence of compiler warnings,
we should use the name category
base as its base class exists to
conditionally provide iterator category.
Excellent. OK.
OK. Uh, let's see onwards concern range of
distance current and could be order N which
is a more expensive check than plus equal.
Uh, where was that happening in
the subtraction? Operator plus SQL.
Ohh, we then possible when it was doing that
check to make sure it didn't go past the end.
Ohh yeah distance current end but
distance current end might be ON because
Endis could us could be a single thing.
It's not necessarily so, yeah.
We haven't required sized Sentinel.
Right now this is only a precondition check,
but it is true that sneaking in order
N validation for potentially huge range
in a precondition check is something
we would not generally want to do.
Avoid that.
Yeah, so are you suggesting restrict
that to say if size Sentinel then if
you check otherwise just hope OK.
That seems reasonable,
especially because range is advanced
would still do. Checking right, we would.
Yeah, or maybe it's a reasonable
access range though.
It is yes, but it does so
random access does not change.
The distance should be order one.
Two iterators as that one
distance between iterator and a
Sentinel may not be computable.
In what right? If they don't really,
unless they model before.
Was that the case where we think like
random access range but the Sentinel is
as soon as you see a null character?
I'm done something like that.
There's a good one. Yeah, OK,
so find the length you need to see.
Yeah, that's interesting.
OK, OK, that makes sense.
So we only had the one call here, right?
Right, yeah, this is actually I didn't
even think of that. That's great.
This could also be computed if
their range was a size range.
Right, we could do the size and subtract the
distance from begin to current and no one.
Yeah, that seems pretty secure
though to have that be the case,
not the size Sentinel.
OK, let's provide some attribution.
Casey Carter.
Noticed on important subtlety here,
thanks.
Aye. Although we have a
random access range here,
computing the distance.
From current to the.
Sentinel end might not be an
order one operation for example.
We could have iterators into
a null terminated string.
Where the iterators are random access,
but the Sentinel.
Is used to stop the range when a null.
Terminator character.
Is encountered. Thus, this is not a.
Thus this would not be because
hypothetical a sized range. And the.
Distance call would be on order N. Sterland
like operation.
Because this is just a precondition check.
We should, uh, guard this
with UM sized Sentinel 4.
To preserve the check for the
vast majority of cases where
the check can indeed be done in.
Constant time.
If it can't, skipping the
check is still conformant.
Should we say that it'll still likely
be caught by range of the advance?
So it will be yeah.
There will be and ranges ranges.
Advance won't advance past,
the ends will still prevent.
The three argument.
OK, sounds this look.
Umm, Casey knows an important
subtlety here, thanks.
Although we have a random access range here,
computing the distance from current to
the Sentinel end might not be an order.
One operation. For example,
we could have iterators into a
null terminated string where
the iterators are random access,
but the Sentinel is used to stop
the range when a null Terminator
character is encountered.
Thus this would not be a sized range,
and the distance call would be an
order N sterlen like operation,
because this is just a precondition check,
we should guard this with size Sentinel 4.
To preserve the check for the vast
majority of cases where the check
can indeed be done in constant time,
if it can't,
skipping the check is still
conformant and arranges.
The advance will still prevent advancement.
Ask the end. So do I go ahead?
We just like.
Check the return value of ranges advance.
You mean like do the advancement
and then and then check if we would
have caused like like if missing is
a number that's bigger than you?
If it doesn't make sense,
then we know that the advance
hit the end and then stopped.
That seems it seems like we need to do.
Some some work to figure out
like exactly what condition.
I think if missing is greater than.
If missing is greater than or
equal to stride.
Then we've gone too far.
Right?
Ohh, because missing the return
value is how much we weren't able
to advance right, right, right, OK?
And it should never be greater than or equal.
Let's try it because.
We didn't advance this far as we should have.
Strider and his stride times N.
Is it just stride? Just straight.
If we try to advance the iterator by two
steps. That means we try to advance the
underlying iterator by two times stride.
OK, two by two strike source two times stride
so the return value is at least stride.
That means we advanced by one time stride.
But we couldn't advance by the other one,
right? We couldn't make the second
step for the overlying iterator.
Because the underlying iterator
didn't have any steps to move.
But what if we're trying to advance
like 10 strides and we were
only able to get through like 7?
The man returned value would be much
greater than stride O3 strides. OK, but OK.
So what if we if it's a fractional
stride that into fractional stride?
That's that's OK, because there is no
actual element that we didn't land on.
Fractional stride means the Mystic past.
The end element is, you know,
not a full number of strides
past the beginning of sorry.
A full number of strides from
the beginning of their age.
And that's OK.
That's a supportive thing.
That's the whole point of storing
missing in the iterators, even.
OK, so you know that we ended up 3 three
real places away from the notional place
where the past the end element was.
Yeah, so you're saying missing being equal
to or greater than stride is the bad case.
Right, sorry, OK.
I think that's simple enough that
that I had to think about it.
I'm like wow man,
counting by like you know, plus three.
That's hard.
That seems reasonable.
I'm a little bit nervous that it
doesn't exactly mirror the standard ease.
I think I'd minimal.
I want to comment saying why
we're doing this weird thing,
but that does seem reasonable.
It also allows us to check
the negative plus equal case,
because right now we don't have
an ideal check for the plus for
for plus equal negative case,
and so this would be that we actually get.
But like a failure.
If you try and, uh, decrement off the front.
Which is something that Tyler pointed out.
Is that true because missing?
If are you suggesting just checking
this one or checking, uh, we,
we should check that we don't even and
then we should check the second one is 0.
Like we should never check that
this return zero. OK, right?
If I understand correctly, can you see?
Tell me on. Right or wrong,
this something's terribly,
terribly wrong in the designer.
In the situation that we're talking about,
Rangers advances in ON operation.
Right, right? The fact that it's
going to advance step by step
and make sure it doesn't go past
the end when we can't compute the
distance between current and end.
Yeah, it's random access that is not allowed.
Prayers are supposed to be constant time.
Seeing a constraint here this maybe we
need and to be a size Sentinel for. Here.
It does seem compelling because
the advances are bounded by end or
at least the the forward one is O.
It's really really an LWG issue.
It's not even like.
And assuming we did a site Sentinel
forward and this check is totally fine.
Yeah yeah, I'm I think I'm inclined to
do that saying yeah, we have a problem.
Yeah, this is wow. OK cool.
OK well I guess I'll delete this.
Should we just file a follow up issue?
And not bother the contributor with this,
uh, horrifyingly messed up standards.
Yeah, yes we should.
We should not make this
the contributors problem.
Definitely don't want to tell
them to go file to get it fixed.
Yeah, let's see can I?
Can I nominate either of you to file that
or should I attitude you to do that myself?
I'll do that right now.
Awesome thanks Casey.
OK, we are improving the standard.
Thank you both for noticing that
I totally glossed over that
I'm trying to be real careful,
like reviewing every single operator.
I'm like.
Oh yeah, distance runner access plus SQL.
You know it's all good,
and iterators and Sentinels are so much
more complicated than the stuff I'm used to.
So lots to learn.
OK, so how far did we get?
We were going through I got through
the iterator so oh that's right,
we got back to the sized view.
Overall class,
and then we stop for questions.
Are there any more questions?
Stands OK,
Tyler was asking what happens if the
minus equal iterator has an offset
that walks past the front of the range.
Let's see,
the standard says that it is
essentially implied we.
I guess we can look at what
the implementation does,
so if you attempt to minus equal
or plus equal by a negative number
past the beginning of the range,
then you're giving a hugely
negative value to advance.
You know we have checking that,
so you actually just trigger
undefined behavior because we don't
store the total beginning anywhere,
so I think it's UB and it's not something
that we can easily check either.
For example, if you have a range,
say everything is like totally normal,
it's like pointers and stuff and
you've got like a million elements,
and you're striding by 10 and
you advance like 5 strides.
You're plus 50,
and then you say OK minus equal 7 strides.
We don't store the original.
Bounds of the range anywhere.
We only have current in the end,
so we have to trust the user that
if we jump back seven strides,
we're not going to jump off the beginning.
So it's just you B.
It's not something we can check,
even in principle.
So we we can check the plus case
because we do have the end,
but we can't check the minus case.
Interesting asymmetry there basically.
OK, and that's all the
issues that are pending.
OK, so let's take a look. Go back here.
We've got about 22 minutes.
It's all the iterator stuff
we've already looked at that.
Here's the class. OK,
maybe we can get through the product code.
That'd be really cool.
And that's the end of the iterator swap.
So now public. We have a.
Constexpr explicit constructor
stride view taking view range
under and then arrange difference.
T view stride.
OK, we're at the top level under
stride under we are strengthened.
We're no, except if is no throw move
constructable vu because we are moving.
It strengthened OK.
Construct range from stood move range,
copy stride if we have continued
debug level creator of 0.
Then verify that the stride
must be greater 0.
Let's make sure that's
an actual precondition.
That listing right precondition, stride,
Greater 0 good we are mandated to move.
That's all good.
OK, we've got some observers.
These should be notice guard concepts,
review base, constant,
wref we're going to strengthen
or accept is nothrow.
Copy Constructable view strengthened.
Requires copy, constructible view.
Return range OK.
Umm, notice guard comes Exper V base ref ref,
again strengthening for nothrow move.
Constructible returns to move range OK.
No discard cuts.
Expert range difference.
T view stride concino
except always return stride.
No discard. Correct Constexpr auto begin.
And then we're strengthening.
We're no, except if this is
no except ranges begin range.
But you got to call there and is no throw,
move constructible V Iterator view.
Because we're going to move an R value out,
is that correct?
Isn't this going to do that?
No, it's one we construct.
Iterator false ranges begin range.
Oh yeah, because this is an iterator,
we've got to move that in.
OK, strengthened requires the said
better not be a simple movie.
Casey question is,
is the lack of a space here
or something that you would
suppress claim format for?
Because this one is not a function call
or you just not care at this point.
Mostly yes. I would.
We have had a couple slip by.
OK, I'm not coming here.
OK, I won't comment here then
and plus I think Clang 15 is
promised to maybe make this better.
Yeah, I'll let that one slide.
Someone else can comment if they want.
Turn, I mean it is a cosmetic issue.
I'm trying to be less nitpicky.
And yeah, I'm OK with that return.
Iterator false brace construct which
is nice following our usual reference
to brace construct temporaries.
When we can this ranges begin base.
Yep, that's all good.
And then if you are a simple view, UM notice,
guard Constexpr auto begin consist.
Let's strengthen the no. Except,
let's make sure it actually strengthened it.
Does making sure it's not typoed.
No, except if we can say ranges begin
base and is no remove constructible
V iterator T constant view.
Requires range of constancio iterator true.
That's the constant.
This ranges begin base, Yep.
OK. And then end.
OK, wow superboss no discard counts.
Expert Auto End we're going to strengthen
here, no, except if no except.
So we're going to say range of
distance range and no except ranges.
End range. We're calling it a lot,
and is nothrow move constructible.
Iterator tview.
OK, that seems fine.
Requires should not be a simple view.
OK, so we're up to here.
OK,
if Constexpr Commons range view
and size range view and forward
range view so when the stars align.
We have a constant auto under
score capital missing.
That doesn't shadow,
because that's not a data member of us.
We are going to static cast because
the subtraction could potentially do
integer promotion to range difference.
T view of stride minus ranges,
distance range base mod stride.
OK this is a pattern we've seen elsewhere.
Where the standard depicts 2 mods,
but this could only be the the
second mod could only do work if we
actually get stride out when we do the
subtraction because we start with stride,
we subtract something that might be
0 to stride minus one inclusive.
If you subtract 0 then you'll get
stride and the mod would do work again,
so we can avoid that second mod by
just checking the quality. Umm?
So I recognize this pattern from elsewhere,
so that's why this is deviating
from the standard.
If missing is exactly equal to stride.
Then we just want to essentially pass zero.
Turn iterator false.
This ranges then range and
use the default of zero there.
Otherwise return Iterator falls to
this range, then range missing.
OK. Yep, that's that.
Elsif constexpr common,
range V and not bidirectional range
V return iterator false.
This ranges end range.
Otherwise return the default
Sentinel and all looks good.
OK.
This doesn't actually call ranges
end more than once through any
given control flow,
it just repeats it three times
and it doesn't always need it,
so repeating it seems reasonable.
There's no real good way to extract it.
And then, oh, we've got another
one hiding here, notice guard,
Constexpr Auto end contest?
And then strengthen.
No, except if no except range
is distance range and no
except range is end range.
Which is slightly overkill because
now I'm seeing that sometimes
if the stars don't align,
we don't even need to call ranges and range,
but when we're strengthening,
it's OK if we don't always strengthen.
That seems fine and is no
through move constructible.
The Iterator T constant view OK strengthened,
so not not seeing any copy paste errors,
which is good,
requires range of constant view OK.
What's that if context were coming
range comes to view and size range,
constant view and forward range
constant view conserto missing is
static cast range difference T.
What did it say? View here.
There's no reason to say cons to you.
UM, stride, minus ranges,
distance range, mod stride, if missing,
is stride return iterator true again,
I'm being careful to look for copy
paste errors. This ranges in range.
Otherwise iterator true.
Add the missing.
Elusive contacts per common arrange concert
view and not bidirectional range console.
View return iterator true
this ranges end range.
Otherwise return default Sentinel.
OK, that's all good.
Getting close to the end here.
No discard conspirator size strengthen no.
No except if no except ranges.
Distance range strengthened
requires size range. V return.
Let's actually look at the
work we're doing here.
Here it is.
Return the internal helper 2 unsigned
like of Division seal of ranges,
distance range stride.
Yep. Man, very similar.
Notice dark sex for auto size contest.
Similarly strengthened require
size range of counts of East
same exact to unsigned like.
And then we've got a.
Deduction guide template
Class R which is class range.
Stride View takes range ref ref
range difference T range do stride
view of views alt range perfect.
And then we've got the
specialization from the synopsis.
Up here, so we've done stride view.
Here's the enabled bar range
template on class of view.
Inline constexpr able enable
bar range tridev is enabled.
Bar range of the underlying V
correct and now the stride function
which is just depicted here.
But we have a pattern that we spam
out namespace view struct under score
stride claim form it off and on because
it doesn't handle this correctly.
That is for indented.
That looks good.
Template on a viewable range range.
Yeah, we're not going to get anything
to pick it down here, are we?
No, not template unviewable range
range no discard because if you call
this thing you really should use what
it returns because export autoprint
Ryan take Ranger frange constraint
difference to range stride concino
except no accept OK this is being.
This is. The standard says it's got to be
like transparent with respect to like all
the things you can observe for an expression
so that this is actually mandatory.
It's not being strengthened.
No, except no, except make a stride
view from stood forward range stride.
I think we do use parentheses here.
I forget if that's observable or not,
but I think this is common.
Requires acquirers.
OK, that's all the same.
Turn on, click format.
And then return the thing, OK?
Playing format off and on again,
making sure they're matched. Umm?
If you just give us a stride,
then we'll use this closure thing.
Template on tie requires constructible
from Katie tie tie.
No Skype sex Prato here.
I'm just going off my memory
of what this should look like.
Take a tie reference stride.
We are no except make sure there's
only 1/2 of gotcha is no through
constructible VKT Tai from Ty return
range closure stride fun Katie Ty four
tie stride inline constexpr stride stride.
Close ranges and and we are
guarded by 23 oh this is good.
Yeah I actually forgot to check
that this is guarded by 23.
It's pretty easy to accidentally
find stuff in 20, but this is good.
OK, that's the product code.
So that leaves just the tests.
We actually have 12 minutes.
I can look at the depth test first.
Copyright license.
Turn on container device level.
Due to the checking ceased to death
because we've got size team somewhere.
Maybe? I don't even see any size T.
I don't see any uses of limits.
Is it just copy? Oh no.
Here's size T-47 here or cdef.
Here's limits, great.
Umm.
Include ranges include test death,
stood stacks,
expert instruments 0123456789 OK,
so the things that can cause errors and
negative stride you can't step backwards.
So if you call.
Umm?
If you try to make a range of stride view,
this is using the almost always
auto pattern that I dislike.
I think I let this slide and other.
Similar death tasks.
I'm so tempted to complain,
but I will not complain here.
Uh, just because I know there
there's a precedent for this.
I think I think it'll
occur if I search for this.
I just like it because it it says an
extra auto where you don't need auto.
You can just name the type directly.
It doesn't buy anything.
Yeah, this is copied from chunk death,
so this is what I get when I let one
occurrence of almost always auto slide.
It just keeps proliferating
throughout the code base.
Umm, I won't complain here.
Maybe I'll go clean it up later.
It's it's more of a prevail.
Yeah, I will complain in product
code like I fill in product code.
This is unnecessarily complicated.
It means it's saying auto but auto
is not actually doing anything.
You're saying the type right there.
It's better to reserve auto for only when
you're doing an actual type deduction,
but I care less about the.
Conventions in test code still won't let
you know if statements without braces slide,
but this I'll let go.
So make a range of stride view some ints
minus one stride must be greater than zero.
If you try to dereference at end.
Get an iterator and you cannot
dereference Dr View and iterator.
I'm just looking for copy paste bring
increment *** end Stride View summons
3 because we've got 10 of them.
Get the end and then increment cannot
increment. Strive you an iterator.
Try to post increment. Yep, that's post.
Try to advance past end.
If you're skipping by three trying
to plus equal by 5 would be 15.
That's too much, can't advance past end.
What if you entered your overflow very
nice and try to take numeric limits?
Put her if divide by two,
but if you're skipping by three,
that's way too much.
Umm,
the parentheses here are not
technically necessary because
actually no we do include Windows 8.
We really do need parenthesis
while it's awful.
I think I think we include
Windows 8 through the depth test.
Can I advance Dr Iterator pass an
integer overflow? Yep, that's right.
It mean this is our machinery if.
Idle is not zero. Do the full test.
That's everything.
Otherwise test only the container debug
level case, which is negative stride overall,
not the iterator stuff.
Agreed, Yep, that looks perfect.
Aside from almost always auto.
Ah, see 8 minutes.
Let's do a quick scan over this.
I got our banner.
We got a bunch of includes.
I won't do an exhaustive audit
of the includes yet.
UM stud.
OK, so can view stride given a range.
Can we form view stride of
forward range R and three OK?
Test 1 given a range and expected.
Using Ford range by the range random range,
common range size range.
I don't actually know why we
use two different usings.
I've seen this elsewhere.
It's not really too bad.
Using range stride view begin
end Iterator Sentinel and Preve
OK. Cuts exportable is it a view.
So this really this does look copy,
paste modified from existing tests,
which is good. It means that it's
going to test all the usual patterns,
so here I'm not being too.
Strict about you know.
Looking at every single thing
in the standard is I just want
to make sure we're following the
usual patterns and that we're not
skipping anything using V using R as
the stride view that it's a view.
It's got to be an input range.
R is a forward range if ranges the
underlying one is same with bidding
with random can't be contiguous
because you're skipping elements.
It should not be default initialize able.
Check barred range,
check the range adapter object
and the closure.
With L value argument so range ref.
Yeah, if you stride with a constant L value.
Olley consonance and see if you're no except.
Yep, as constant here with R value.
So if you move reference from the range U.
And here we're calling move.
And the contributor did note that they
were going to call us to move explicitly,
so we'll accept that for now,
and possibly in the future.
We'll just suppress that cling warning,
because that really does not
provide value in our tests.
With Constar value argument.
Move as constant.
OK, validate the deduction guide.
Yeah, like,
here's the only case where I
believe auto is reasonable.
If you're using the same as to check
what the auto is, then sure, go ahead.
Skyview braced for in Range Range 3 validity,
strive, view stride as member function.
Call it.
And then make sure it's range difference
T and you can call it on constant.
Check size. So should we.
If you're size range of size.
Should be unsigned like call range of size.
The constant version for constar.
See about empty. Can't remember
empty if you're forward or sized.
Call empty the constant version.
Yep, constant re validate the content.
Certain range is equal if you're not
a forward range, just return true.
Then strive you begin.
Check the begin.
If the view is copy constructable.
They can.
Get a second one and then call
it begin on that start view.
Begin on console so there's all the costars.
Yeah, stride view,
end.
Yeah, that if we. Advance back one
that we get the. Uh, same value here.
Yeah, looks good, strive you and consist.
That replied cost everything.
Yeah, I'm going through it a little
bit quicker than I usually would.
Do you interface data you should not
have data because you're not contiguous.
If you're empty, return true.
Now we can actually access
at least one element.
Uhm, we can index if your random access.
If you're constant constant,
ya chick has constant here.
Do we have front?
Do we have front for contst?
Do we have back?
And then do we have back for contst?
Strive view iterator of modifiable.
Check the iterator category.
That's the intercat.
And then the underlying 1.
Yeah, and then if you're forward.
You can default constructor forward
iterator compare against default 70.
Using not equal.
Check the quality of iterator against itself.
Forward range this is post increment.
Then also pre increment post Doc and
Predock for random access ranges.
You can do plus equal minus equal.
C square bracket. I plus 2/2 plus,
I subtract subtract 2 iterators,
including opposite way.
Do we subtract default Sentinel?
Yep, that's going down there comparisons.
Lastly, SQL greater, greater, equal.
We're also going to use space shipping,
that's good.
And if it's a size Sentinel four,
we can use Sentinel subtract,
Sentinel or reverse.
See what the base is.
Also, on an R value stride
view iterator consist.
Let's look at the iterator category.
It's expert Bool Constructable
from nonconstant OK This
is testing that conversion.
If forward range comes to war.
OK comparisons with the default Sentinel.
Check the concentrator not
equal default Sentinel,
but if you advance one it is quality
operators between 2 conspirators.
You have constar is a forward range.
I posted a should be voyeured.
Yep, I directional range.
Random access range operations
plus equal minus equals square
bracket plus two 2 + - 2.
Let's track two iterators, reverse it.
Compare them spaceship them.
Cross comparisons these are tricky.
These are cause trouble for us.
Before I was hoping to see them and I have,
so that's great modifiable
compared to consist.
Here. Cure they're only forming.
Some, but not all patterns.
Just the ones that are true.
Basically, I'm OK with this,
it would be it would be.
I mean, we could technically compare,
like not I greater CI 2 for example.
So we get the all operators and all
patterns of constant on constant.
But given that they're all
following the same sort of system,
this this would be sufficient to catch any.
Cases worth convergence don't work,
so I'm not too concerned here. Umm?
This is not testing a cross comparison.
These are all consed.
This looks like a copy paste
like it's intended for.
I to be used here. Let's see,
these comparisons were CI CI 2.
Here were just replacing CI with I.
I'm almost certain this is a bug or
essentially missed test coverage in fact.
Yeah, they're there.
The lines are repeated.
They're in a different order,
but they're repeated.
I think this is a deficiency.
Include the cross comparisons.
It appears that the spaceship.
Casts here aren't testing
cross comparisons between
constant and non constant.
Was it intended to use I instead of?
CI here.
Yes, found a potential copy paste
issue with one missing character.
I am fully awake OK before
my caffeine runs out.
We've got a couple more minutes.
I think we can finish this test if
constexpr symbol for symbol T constant
iterator T constant V constancy.
The range call ranges size,
which we did not have a using for
same age range difference tea.
Yeah, if you subtract it so size
4 you can do the subtraction.
OK validate constant ref for the base.
Yep, that looks fine.
That looks fine too.
But some ints
01234567891011. You'd be surprised
how often just incrementing numbers.
You get a typo in there stride result O369
struct instantiate or call for summons,
test one and then some of this
machinery that tests a whole
bunch of different combinations.
I've just sort of glazing over
this because almost certainly
copy paste from elsewhere.
Instantiation test test all input
and forward range permutations.
Test only interesting comment size.
When the base range is an input range,
the view sensitive to different
saying the view sensitive to
category commonality and size,
but oblivious to differencing and Roxy Ness.
OK.
There's a move only view validate
views that are copyable.
Got a span of constant move.
Only views good mix input forward
bidi and random. Non views.
At a vector and a forward
list empty range with nothing.
OK. That looks good.
OK, so we actually got through everything.
A few changes requested.
Overall pretty good.
The one last thing I want to check
before I submit this is to see if
we have any other currencies of
those missed cross comparison tests,
because if this test was
copy pasted and modified.
This could occur elsewhere in the code base,
so let's see if we have any other
comments that say cross comparisons.
I would guess this was all copied
from chunk view and then altered.
Yeah, cross comparisons.
We got I here but this is CI.
Umm ohh no this says Ohh comparisons.
Cross comparisons interesting ohhh.
Originally we had comparisons.
We had cross comparisons and then we had a
separate section that's just testing OK.
Can we 3 way compare these things?
But we weren't testing 3
way cross comparisons.
Yeah, it was underneath this comment,
but it wasn't intended to
group slide exact same.
But when this test was added.
It's a little bit different pattern.
We've got the comparisons here.
And then these cross comparisons so.
I think it's not a pre-existing issue,
and the other tests maybe.
Maybe they should be enhanced or something,
but here it really is repeating those tests.
OK, so I think we don't need to go
fix up the rest of the infra or the
test coverage and this is just I.
Yeah that's fine. OK, so I think we
don't have a huge preexisting issue.
OK, I will request changes.
Any other comments?
Some comments about?
Should we just define no
min Max in our test code?
I believe that as annoying
as the status quo is,
what we're doing is reasonable and the
reason why is if we define the no min,
Max macro and our test code
for our convenience to not have
to parenthesize min and Max
in the presence of Windows H,
we could accidentally miss cases
in product code where we really
do need to parenthesize min Max.
Having the test code to be exposed
to the same macros as user code
means that we will be forced to be
disciplined in the product code,
so as annoying as it is,
I think the absence of.
And Max is reasonable.
We did originally use known min Max
in some of the tools like validate
used to or parallelize used to
include Windows H and then define
nominal Max because it's just a tool,
it's not product code,
but for the actual product
code and test code.
I think that what we're doing is reasonable.
OK request changes.
Do I need to add any comments?
I think I will.
I'll just say thanks,
this looks great.
Found a small number of issues.
Should be quite good dress.
Yeah, nothing that I found really required
like extensive refactor or anything.
The biggest issue we found
was in the standard itself,
with the difference whatever.
OK, I found a small number issue.
Should be quick to address.
I think they also should get a smile cat.
OK, quest changes.
Yeah, so double checking all
my comments made it there.
The race condition with the other
PR that I've got the typo and
the feature to macro tests triple
mirror that Nicole's offered to do.
Thank you reversing these parameters.
Using the ranges macro,
don't shadow iterator base.
What's going on with the cross comparisons?
Yeah, all of those are isolated.
They should be pretty easy to fix.
OK, cool. Nicole,
do you want me to design you while
we're waiting for changes here?
OK, that's fine. OK.
In fact, these are.
These are small enough that if the the
contributor doesn't get back to us,
I could easily validate and push changes,
but in this case we found enough
that asking them to take a look is,
I think, reasonable. Umm?
Yeah, OK, and I don't see any
other questions in the chat,
so I think we can call this the end.
Thanks for watching this video code
review and we'll see you next time.